[Música]
a las puertas del desierto con su
majestuoso fuerte youtube encarna todo
el esplendor de las ciudades de rajastán
la tierra de los reyes en el noroeste de
la india
fue fundada en el siglo 15
la mítica ciudad también es conocida
como la ciudad azul por las numerosas
casas pintadas de este color
una escala de azules y un laberinto de
callejones en el que vive richard dios y
home hora de empezar y pintarlo todo de
azul su familia ha vivido aquí durante
tres generaciones y cada año cuando se
acerca el invierno se encarga de pintar
su casa
es una antigua tradición aquí todo el
mundo pinta sus casas de azul así que yo
también lo hago
originalmente fueron los brahmanes la
casta más alta de la india quienes
empezaron a pintar las paredes con este
color para distinguirse de otras
comunidades
al pintar las paredes de color azul los
brahmanes hacían que sus casas pudieran
reconocerse por lo que el rey podía
identificarlos desde su fortaleza y
sabía dónde encontrarlos
esta fortaleza construida en 1459 se
levanta sobre una gigantesca roca
la antigua residencia de los marajás de
youtube tiene más de 400 metros de
longitud
[Música]
un gigantesco palacio con numerosos
patios interiores y fachadas
magníficamente esculpidas
este guía turístico es un apasionado de
esta antigua residencia real
ahora estamos en un lugar donde tuvo
lugar la coronación
en este asiento de mármol es donde se
sentaba al rey la ceremonia se celebraba
en este patio pero sólo podían asistir
los hombres las mujeres tenían que
ocultar sus rostros y así que observaban
desde los balcones de ayer network favor
a 135 metros de altura la ciudadela fue
uno de los mejores sistemas de defensa
de rajastán e incluso fue una de las
localizaciones para una de las películas
de batman
en la película el actor sale de un poso
que fue creado especialmente para el
rodaje que es donde estamos ahora
cuando batman sale de este pozo mira
hacia arriba y ve este fuerte este
fuertes muy conocidos ha utilizado en
muchas otras películas
[Música]
para mirarlo en todo su esplendor
go
esta turista decidió lanzarse al vacío a
20 metros de altura las tirolinas llevan
a los valientes por sus vertiginosas
murallas y este ingeniero informático
del sur del país soñaba con lanzarse
para disfrutar de la espléndida vista
[Aplausos]
a la vista del fuerte es genial desde
aquí también se pueden ver lagos y la
ciudad azul fue increíble
[Música]
símbolo vivo de un pasado glorioso
jodhpur alberga en realidad dos palacios
desde 1929 los marajás de la ciudad
abandonaron el fuerte para instalarse en
este palacio hoy aunque ya no tienen
ningún poder político siguen viviendo
aquí pero parte del edificio fue
convertido en un hotel de lujo
[Música]
bienvenidos al palacio es un placer
recibir hemos hecho de mármol y piedra
arenisca rosa el palacio es testigo de
la opulencia que los antiguos reyes de
rajastán querían mostrar y
ahora estamos en la parte más gravosa
del palacio que llamamos el domo en
central park aquí es donde el marajá
solía recibir a los invitados cuando
llegaban al palacio decían sin duda la
hermosa vez
la mítica yo pura majestuosa ciudad azul
del desierto compite con la belleza de
los brillantes colores del cielo de
rajastán